- [Instructor] Welcome to the Khan Academy
2016 Annual Report.
In the actual text of the report,
we're going to go into a lot more detail
on the financials and other things
but I'm hoping here to
give you an overview.
Big picture 2016 was a
great year for Khan Academy.
The impact has continued to grow
in the double digit percentages
and is accelerating.
Over a 100 million people
used our platform last year,
people from almost every
country in the world
and they spent an aggregate
of 5.6 billion total minutes.
So one of the areas that
we've really started
to accelerate in 2016 was
in content development.
Many people associate Khan
Academy with mathematics
but what we've really been investing in
is going beyond mathematics.
We really wanna cover all of
the core academic subjects
that you consider to be
part of your education
all the way through the core of college
and it's not just videos.
We're doing a lot on practice
and we're doing a lot of written articles.
2016 was a very big deal
in terms of a partnership
with the College Board.
A few years ago, they
reached out to us, said,
we are going to revamp the SAT
and as part of that, we want to address
at least the perception of inequity
that's been around for decades
and the reason why they wanted
to partner with Khan Academy
is traditional test prep was
associated with gaming an exam.
It wasn't about real learning
but they saw that we were
focused on filling in gaps
in students' understanding.
So we launched with the College Board
and what we've seen over
the course of the year
is Khan Academy is now used more
than all of paid test prep combined
and we're seeing that usage
very broad and very deep
and what's been even more exciting
is the PSAT which is taken
in 10th or 11th grade
by 80% of American high school students,
in the past, that was just a
random practice test you took
but now it acts as a
diagnostic for Khan Academy.
You can take your PSAT scores,
give permission to Khan Academy
and then Khan Academy's software
knows your strengths and weaknesses,
not just in math but in
reading and writing as well
and can immediately
give you practice items
that are essentially weak point training
and even more powerful,
we've been able to follow
students from that PSAT
through their work on Khan Academy
to eventually taking the SAT
to understand the efficacy
of this entire ecosystem
and what you see here on the slide
is some of the preliminary
results for arguably the largest
personalized learning
study ever conducted.
With over 300,000 students,
we saw that those who
prepared on Khan Academy
for at least 20 hours
saw twice the growth
from the PSAT to the SAT
than they would typically see
and this is just the beginning.
We're working with the
College Board very closely
to do even further studies
and we've also seen that it
doesn't stop at 20 hours.
The more time that
students put in practice,
the more gains we're seeing.
Another really exciting event in 2016
is that Duck Duck Moose
became part of Khan Academy.
Duck Duck Moose, I would argue,
was the best early learning
app company out there.
In 2016, the founding team
said we would rather see our
work having a social mission
and reaching as many students as possible
especially those that are most in need
and so they became part
of our team in 2016
and going forward,
we're going to be working
on early learning apps
that holistically approach
reading, writing, mathematics
starting at pre-kindergarten
and then taking students
through early elementary school.
International continues
to be a very big part
of Khan Academy where
roughly 1/3 of our usage
is outside of the United States.
We have increased our focus
on India, Mexico and Brazil
and going forward, we're
building tools and platforms
to allow each geography
to be even more localized
to their specific needs
and going forward, there's
a lot of exciting things.
What you see here is a screenshot
for the student facing experience
for back to school 2017
where students can tell Khan Academy
what classes they're taking,
what grade they're in
and then Khan Academy
can personalize to them
and also have game mechanics
so that the students are
motivated to move forward.
You can see that right over here
once you get into a unit page.
Of course, you see the videos,
you see the practice items here
but we are also adding diagnostic quizzes
and unit tests as well.
What you see here is our
assignments functionality
where a teacher can assign
any piece of content
on Khan Academy.
This is a teacher assigning
some practice content.
They can assign it to particular students
in a particular class.
They can set a due date.
They can then see a readout
of which students
completed which assignments
and then they can see which items
gave the students the most difficulty
so that they can review
it in class the next day.
On top of all of this,
we have a program called LearnStorm
which is a learning challenge
that schools, teachers,
students participate in
that celebrate the growth mindset.
The more students can
show grit, perseverance
as they work through
practice on Khan Academy,
the more awards and
recognition the students,
their classrooms, their teachers
and their schools will get.
We've piloted it in several
geographies in the past
and 2017 is gonna be the first time
that we do this on a nationwide scale.
So there's a lot going on at Khan Academy.
What I just covered is
really just a sample of it
but we're really grateful
for your support.
We have a big mission.
A free, world-class education
for anyone, anywhere
and some of y'all have been
with us for many years.
When we were just starting in
2007 out of a walk-in closet,
this type of a mission would
have seemed frankly delusional
but because of your
support, your partnership,
all of the work that we've
been able to do together
with governments, with
teachers, with students,
it's no longer just a dream.
It's really happening
and the momentum that we've
built together in 2016
is continuing to accelerate into 2017
and I expect it's going to
accelerate in 2018 and beyond
so that as we look back
in a decade or two,
we'll say, how could
we ever imagine a world
where there wasn't a free
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere?